hi there today we're looking at
discriminating systems gender race and
power NII by Sarah Myers West Meredith
Whitaker and Kate Crawford of the AI now
Institute which is a part of New York
University or associated with it this is
not as much paper as it is a report kind
of summarizing current literature and
also kind of an opinion piece a slash
recommendation giving document yes
so we'll dive into it as you can see
from the index it's quite a long report
and we we we don't have time to go into
all of it
actually we don't have time to go into
most of it I just hope to kind of point
out what the main arguments and themes
are in the report kind of what it's
trying to say pick out some interesting
things and summarize it to the best of
my ability also give it a little
critique so let me actually go ahead and
try to state the the kind of core the
kind of core arguments that report is
trying to make because it's not really
clear from reading it and you have to
kind of read the whole thing and then it
kind of becomes clear what the argument
is I feel though they they somehow
stated in the introduction numerous
times in various ways so I might just be
not as as a tenth of a reader at first
son but all right
so here's the argument and I really hope
I'm representing this correctly we have
a problem currently that sometimes AI
systems can exhibit what we usually call
bias and we don't mean mathematical bias
like bias-variance tradeoff we mean bias
in a societal sense let's say bias
against certain types of people where
they shouldn't exist so for example let
me draw an AI system and I'll just draw
a little computer screen with a little
light bulb all right
because it's smart this is an AI system
and the AI system and they give numerous
examples one example they give is for is
like face recognition algorithm that is
much more accurate on faces of white
males as opposed to darker skinned
females so let me draw like two curves
to represent these distributions are
unequal and so the AI system exhibits
some bias with respect to some kinds of
people with an especially protected
attributes and in this report they focus
mainly on gender and race so that's what
we're gonna talk about the second thing
they observe so this observation one the
second thing they observe is I'm gonna
draw some generic people here that
represent the workforce of AI so the AI
workforce is classified as all the
people that work on AI B that University
researchers or within companies building
AI products or deploying them so this is
the workforce and they observe that
there is a unequal distribution among
the AI workforce and so this
distribution I'm also going to do this
for unequal distribution there's an
unequal distribution in the I workforce
most notably it's predominantly males
who work on AI and and also white people
are over-represented compared to the
world population at large so that's kind
of the two observations they make and
now what they claim is that the
inequality or the the unequal
representation in the workforce is
causing the bias in the AI systems so
they're basically saying the these AI
systems are biased because that the
workforce is unequally distributed and
also they claim in a less powerful sense
I feel what they claim there is a loop
that this then leads back that because
there is bias in the AI system that
again leads to an unequal more ani
distribution of the workforce so the the
core argument really is as they set out
to do like in the introduction and also
claim that they have done in the
conclusion is to demonstrate these two
directions here in in a causal way so
the the systems are biased because there
is an unequal representation in the
workforce and that feeds back so the the
argument is that if you want to fix the
bias here if you want to fix that then
you will have to fix it via making the
workforce more what they call diverse so
less less unilaterally distributed
towards white males that's that's kind
of the the final conclusion if you read
their report and the recommendations
that's that's mainly what they're going
for yeah so my opinion or in my opinion
having read the report a couple of times
is that as as I see it they really don't
demonstrate these links so they get they
give examples of this and they give
examples of this right they they show
that the workforce I know is unequally
distributed they show that AI systems
can exhibit such bias but they never
actually show these links in my opinion
they they don't show this so if if you
make the claim that in order to fix the
bias in AI systems you must fix the
unequal representation in the workforce
I would need a argument that says
because there is unequal representation
there for a therefore B therefore C
therefore bias like a in actual argument
to follow that the says because of this
that because of that that and so on like
this is just not there like they they
simply show parallels they simply show
that these two things exist and they
just list example after example of that
and the the the I I don't think they
make this argument what I think I think
too
- also the other direction they don't
really make this argument they accept it
very in in like one frame in one case
where you know if you give them benefit
of the doubt what I also I think is that
it appears like like the article if you
read it and I encourage you to read it
if you have some time it makes a lot of
sense if you have already accepted this
conclusion like if you've already
accepted this then it's like oh yeah
because the I feel this is just a text
where the confirmation bias is so high
just the way it's written that it must
make a lot of sense to someone who's
already kind of in on this conclusion
but to someone who isn't sold yet like
myself I am just not finding this
convincing at all the second thing is
that it very much feels like this isn't
like a discovery or something but
someone actually set out with the goal
to address this here with the goal of I
want companies to hire more of these
people or of certain kinds of people or
to become more diverse or to promote
more of a certain type of people and now
I'm going to find reasons for this and
the reason is like oh look at look at
this bias here this is cost this is
caused by this other thing and therefore
we must fix this other thing it very
much feels like someone setting out with
already the conclusion in mind rather
than this being an honest investigation
but yeah I mean read it for yourself I
can't prove the absence of an argument
by not reading every single line and I
can't read every single line because it
will just get very long and boring but
read it yourself and and I'm I find I
think I'm pretty I'm pretty I've read it
numerous times with really an open mind
to be convinced that there is an
argument in there but I don't think
there is
or I don't think there is a very strong
argument for this all right let this
first part here is more or less a
summary so research findings is more or
less a summary and we'll get to these
things as they are important then they
state recommendations right at the
beginning so actually you'd have to read
the article first this is kind of more
of an abstract section but since it's
right here we'll kind of jump right into
it so these are recommendations and I've
claimed they don't really show a
connection but they actually just show
examples examples of this and examples
of this and parallel them and this is
reflected in like every single section
including here in the recommendations
they have recommendations for improving
workplace diversity and they have
recommendations for addressing bias and
discrimination in AI systems right so
all right it in my case if you make this
argument I would I would feel you'd also
make recommendations for breaking these
links but or argue why they can't be
broken but all right let's jump into
some of them and it is really a mixed
bag here really um so some
recommendations I am really in favor of
just from from the go not even you don't
even need the article for those here
published rent harassment and
discrimination transparency reports
including number of claims over time the
types of claims submitted and actions
taken so it's known that especially in
these larger companies sexual harassment
claims often go down in either
bureaucracy or are kind of hushed under
the table or something like this what
you have to recognize is that a human
resource department of a large company
isn't there to serve the Human Resources
it's there to serve the company
providing Human Resources that that's
why a sexual harassment claim to an HR
department is just a potential lawsuit
and that's why they don't want to take
it seriously except for it must go away
really quickly so I think to kind of
force companies or to ask companies to
be more transparent to take more
seriously these are keys
of sexual harassment and assault and
also discrimination he's a very valuable
goal and I fully fully support this also
the here commit to transparency around
hiring practices especially hi regarding
how candidates are leveled compensated
and promoted that also is in the larger
the company gets the less transparent
this process usually becomes or the more
bureaucratic the more people are able to
game it and so on and distort it so I
feel it's it's always good to be
transparent around around okay this
person provides this much value to the
company therefore they should be
compensated in according like according
to that or at least be be transparent
about it so these are the kind of
recommendations I like then
recommendations that really go into a
different direction is something like
this year change hiring practices to
maximize diversity and this is kind of
reflect I'm not going to go near this
reflected in other in other points
increase the number of people of color
women and other underrepresented groups
at senior leadership levels of AI
companies across all departments so
these things they are usually within
like company diversity goals and so on
doesn't really say how to do it but then
the I mean as as such they're not really
recommendations yet they're more like
goals but your recommendation 7 I think
is the the crucial one ensure executive
incentive structures are tied to
increases in hiring and retention of
underrepresented groups
so this is it's a bit of coded language
but but here they talk about executive
incentive structure tied to hiring and
retention of under represented groups
this basically means if you are a
manager or someone in charge of hiring
or promoting and you hire or promote a
underrepresented person and since
they're talking about gender and race
here if you it means if you hire or
promote
a person of color or a woman in this
case you will be compensated more so at
the end of the year you'll somehow have
more money like more bonuses or more
base comp or more equity or something
like you will get more money so this
this recommendation is a direct call to
hire based on race and gender so this
this is a direct call to racist and
sexist hiring basically to discriminate
people according to their skin color and
according to their gender which I I mean
how how is this okay with anyone like
how can anyone how are people even able
to state this and in in like a high
profile report like this and get away
with it and not have people criticize
them this directly calls for people to
be treated according to their gender and
race and probably as directly as you can
go without getting into actual legal
trouble but yeah I'm I'm really really
against such such practices I mean yeah
that's I just I just don't know how this
how this can ever how this can ever be
thought of as a good thing by anyone all
right so well yeah in my mind this
recommendation and this recommendation
kind of our counter to each other
because if if I commit to transparency
our people are okay now I can come I can
transparently commit to to be racist I
guess but if I say okay I'm gonna come
and promote people based on how much
value they provide to the company then
yeah I'd much rather have that than
saying I'm going to comp and promote
people based on their skin color all
right so let's actually jump into the
report I'm not gonna these
recommendations for addressing bias and
discrimination in systems this these are
fairly um general in common so as well
as I said we'll jump most of the things
in the report so introduction so they
start out with there is a diversity
crisis
the industry they give like some numbers
like 15% of our research stuff and 10%
at Google so 15% of Facebook or women so
these are some kind of fairly known
statistics about how the AI field is
gender and race skewed currently so they
say they claim involved the diversity
problem is not just about women it's
about gender race and most fundamentally
about power it affects how a our
companies work or products get built who
they're designed to serve and who
benefits from their development so this
I find this this this word power and
this notion of power a lot in this
report it's it appears again and again
and again in in like power dynamics and
power dynamics among groups it's like a
worldview it paints like a worldview
where these different gender and race
groups kind of struggle against each
other to gain power over another and
whoever's in power will try to remain in
power in alliance with their gender and
race group and try to keep the other
groups down it's I don't I'm not sure
that's the correct view of the world in
my mind the world is comprised of
individual people that want to achieve
something for themselves and they would
like to prop themselves up whereas in
this worldview it's like I'm going to
use the power of my group to keep the
other groups down I don't know which
worldview you subscribe to but I find
the the world is comprised of
individuals yeah and this is not
discrediting that some people have it
harder because of their gender or race
but to see the entire world as a power
struggle between these groups to me it's
it's a yeah and I'm not gonna point out
everywhere it appears this power
wording but it appears a lot and its
really shapes how the report reads you
have to you have to kind of remember if
you're a white male and currently the
field is comprised of 90% white males
you if you have like 10 like 10 hours
let's say you have to drive to 10 hours
to do something right you can either
choose to put down some other groups
like put down groups that you're not
part of or you can choose to invest
these 10 hours in putting up yourself
you right so if if I like I profit if
I'm a white male I profit minimally from
keeping the other groups down because
guess what I still have to compete with
the like one billion other white males
there are that's that it's not gonna
help me to keep down anyone else and
especially like it's it's moronic I does
that who like has Alliance except most
French people like to their race or
gender rather than to the people they
admire and respect and like to work with
so I'm gonna find like 10 hours today
I'm gonna rather spend this in propping
up myself compared to everyone else and
I don't care what gender race they are
and so that to me that's so much more
accurate or I don't know plausible over
worldview but just be aware that this
report really takes on the language of
kind of groups and power between groups
and groups trying to you know kind of
gain power and keep in keep power and
keep others from having power alright
say say to date the diversity problems
of the industry and the issues of bias
and the systems it builds have tended to
be considered separately we suggest that
these are two versions of the same
problem issues of discrimination in the
workforce and in system buildings are
deeply intertwined challenge and
moreover tackling the
of bias within technical systems
requires addressing workforce diversity
and vice-versa so the UM I think this
this here actually is like how I
described the argument and they kind of
restated multiple times in a bit
different way but I think this is the
core and I really think I'm not
misrepresenting the article here in that
this is what they are setting out to do
they're setting out to say okay the
diversity the kind of unequal
representation in the workforce and the
bias in some AI systems are causally
linked to each other and tackling one
requires tackling the other so yeah if
I'm misrepresenting them let me know but
I really think I'm accurately
representing their argument so what they
what they do as I said is they give
examples of one and of the other and
also they really they're really unkind
of discrediting the the kind of issues
to solve problems of bias in a different
way so they they point a little bit to
this here in the introduction they say
in the face of growing evidence the air
research community and the industry
producing our products have begun
addressing the problem of bias by
building on a body of work of fairness
accountability and transparency so
fairness accountability and transparency
research concerns these these issues for
one is research showing that some
products are unfair or on transparent
and so on and on the other hand it's
trying to devise algorithms that are
more fair according to some notions or
more accountable and transparent which
means that the algorithm can kind of say
why it made a certain decision rather
than it being a deep learning system
that you don't really have an insight
these fields are active fields of
research definitely very interesting to
look into so but they they kind of it is
not already here but they say yeah we
have adjusting air systems that and
produce a result the deemed fair by one
of my various mathematical definitions
you can already see in the language here
they don't really like this research and
they are trying in this report to kind
of discredit it or at least claim that
it doesn't solve the whole problem
because their point is of course you
have to address this diversity issue in
the workforce in order to fix the
problems yeah so to this I just want to
say no like if you can I mean you can
criticize the the fairness and
accountability and transparency research
field in that they haven't solved the
problem fully yet but in principle if I
have an algorithm if I'm being delivered
an algorithm right and the the fairness
of literature has been applied to that
algorithm and someone tells me I
guarantee you here is a proof the
algorithm is fair right then I really
don't care
who made that algorithm as long as it's
fair the problem is fixed if the bias is
gone the problem is fixed and I don't
care who fix it I don't care if the
person who fix it is black or white or
purple then the problem is fixed and
they they really have to really try to
just make the counter-argument here is
that no that's it's not enough but I
claim yes it if you can actually solve
the the fairness problem
technically then you have solved the
fairness problem yeah the only thing you
can do is claim that it is not good
enough yet but not that it's funda to
make the argument that it's
fundamentally flawed approach and I
don't think they succeed in doing that
here yeah so they go on to say we should
expand to consider not only how it
itools can be biased technically but how
they are shaped by the environments in
which are built in and the people that
build them again this this focus like
who builds the AI system I don't care I
care what it does right as much as if
some if I hear an argument for
against something I don't care who makes
the argument right I care what the
argument says this is it's like an ad
hominem attack for an entire community
that's kind of how this this article
this report shows or is it appears to me
so they say currently large-scale AI
systems are developed almost exclusively
in a handful of technology companies in
a small set of elite university
laboratories spaces that in the West
tend to be extremely white affluent
technically oriented and male so yeah
they're their problem that's their
fundamental problem here that these
these spaces are skewed in one direction
interestingly enough their problem is
not so much that it's that they're all
in the same place right that they all
live like 20 miles from each other in
around San Francisco that's that seems
to be not a problem at all as long as we
get to like enough people of color and
women into these twenty miles but yeah
so that that's pointing out T the
problem here or the yeah kind of issue
they have all right so they go on just
kind of wanna highlight again they say
both within the spaces where AI is being
created and the logic of how AI systems
are being designed so paralleling the
two things the cost of bias harassment
and discrimination are borne by the same
people gender minorities people of color
other underrepresented groups then they
also say similarly the benefits of such
systems from profit to efficiency accrue
primarily to those are already in
positions of power tend to be white
educated and male so they again they say
the this points to a systemic
relationship between patterns of
exclusion within the field of AI in the
industry driving its production on the
one hand and the biases that manifest in
the logics and applications of yet
knowledge is on the other and they try
to make this connection because they say
the cost and the benefit of these two
things are overlap in the people that
wear it costs any benefits and I really
again it's just a parallel but I really
even don't think that's true because
they the kind of the kind of argue
against themselves later so they always
say we have to look at again they should
against the take much more than the
technically driven problem-solving they
they point to this so a research
requires looking at gender and race as
categories within which you must think
well
in short sorry studies of discriminatory
systems we need to ask who is harmed who
benefits who gets to decide so it's it's
kind of who bears the cost who bears the
benefits and who has the power so that's
yeah and again it's we seek to
understand how AI disadvantages some we
also consider how it works to the
advantage of others so keep that in mind
that's kind of the lens through how they
analyze the this thing again wonder
technologist power relationships and
centers equity injustice that's they
they want to see this bigger picture so
that's yeah keep yeah you again keep
that in mind so they go into a section
called which humans are in the loop how
workforces and AI systems interact so
this kind of from the title of this
section you think okay here's where we
get in here's where we make the argument
and they start by listing examples of
how AI systems can be discriminatory and
first they go into an example of Amazon
had developed an experimental hiring
tool to help rank job candidates by
learning from its past reference
preference
Amazon hoped that the resume scanning
tool will be able to efficiently
identify qualified applicants comparing
their applications to previous hires the
system quickly began to downgrade
resumes from candidates who attended all
women's colleges along with any resumes
that included the word women's after
uncovering this bias Amazon engineers
tried to fix the problem by directing
the system to treat these terms in a
neutral manner the company eventually
abandoned the tool when they were unable
to ensure that the algorithm would not
be biased against women gender-based
discrimination was built too deeply
within the system and in Amazon's past
hiring practices to be uprooted using a
purely technical approach so this just
the way is written I find to be I find
to be quite dishonest but let's I let's
analyze what what happened here so their
final claim is that gender-based
discrimination was built too deeply
within the system to be uploaded using a
purely technical approach so this is one
of their arguments they say technical
approaches they don't help because the
Amazon engineers tried to fix the
problem all right
but we're when they were unable to
ensure that the algorithm would not be
biased against women so if you if you
read this you really I mean I really get
the impression that's not what happened
here
what happened here most probably is
Amazon built this tool okay and it fed
in its past hires and we know of issues
of like data set bias bias inherent in
data sets so if your data set is skewed
the AI tends to pick up on the skewed
data set and become skewed itself okay
so I actually would argue that most or
all of the examples they stay stayed in
here are examples of such biased data
sets and not so the the cause of the
bias is the data set that they
straining and not the person that ran
the code or built the algorithm to train
it on or build the deployment um
and so but it doesn't matter your a your
ear Amazon you built this tool and you
realize oh it discriminates against
people having women's on their CV so
this is a pretty bad PR wise so you tell
your engineers engineers fix the problem
so the engineers go fix the problem they
come back and say okay we fix the
problem
and then what you do is you say okay
engineers can you insure me that the
algorithm would not be biased against
women because if only the slightest bias
exists if only it doesn't even have to
be if one journalist finds one example
where there is a down rank because I add
the word women's then we are screwed
right and the engineers will say no we
can't guarantee that it's a deep
learning system or something right we we
can't like give you a proof that it's
not biased if you're a smart executive
at that point you'll scrap the tool
because the potential PR downside are
just huge and probably they've also
realized it's not that handy to have
this this two will compare to their
recruiters doing their job because their
recruiters might actually be you know
good and have been doing this for a
while so due to the fact that this tool
was scrapped is probably much more a
result of a PR disaster but also
independent of that you say gender-based
discrimination sorry
gender-based discrimination was built to
the play within the system to be
uprooted using a purely technical
approach it's just I mean what is what
is this this is just trying to discredit
this kind of technical technical going
about solving this problem but I'm
pretty sure if someone comes to me and
says here I have this tool and I can
mathematically prove to you that it's
not biased
then it's not then the problem is solved
and also I really don't see how the
person training the algorithm or the the
personally researching such an algorithm
has any influence over how the algorithm
works because they're not the ones
making the data set or if they are yeah
then they can make a better data set
also if a person comes and makes a
better data set that will fix the
problem and it doesn't matter what skin
color the person has that makes the
better data set so all of this this link
is just not demonstrated here or
anywhere here at all but this this here
is the closest Amazon that this report
actually comes to making this point so
before I draw drew this thing work force
AI bias right so this this link since it
here the AI system is used for hiring
the workforce so at least one could make
a claim that this link is somewhat
demonstrated but I this it's a weak case
I would agree but this is the closest
they come so there and but then to go
this direction you have to somehow argue
well of the the work force somehow makes
the AI system biased no the work force
influences the data set i if the AI is
trained so if a hiring a I how do you
train a hiring AI you optimally train it
on the performance so this this employee
here is going to have a performance over
time right and the AR system will look
at that performance over time so if the
AR system even if it's initially biased
because it learns from the risk
recruiters it will learn that okay
actually if I always forego these women
then I don't get as much performant of a
workforce so I should correct for that
so if you trained AI system on a good
metric then and then this problem will
Eva even out itself so but again this
yeah this this is this could be
considered like
one point in the argument but I think
it's a very weak point and only because
the AI system is actually used for
hiring where I think the point they're
making is a much larger one is the
general bias in the AI systems
contributes to the work force imbalances
and there you somehow have to say that
okay the AI system somehow influences
society at large and society at large
then go leads to the work force being
skewed I don't yeah that it's just not
strong enough in my opinion and the
other direction also isn't isn't strong
here but again the examples only get
weaker from here on they go on they say
this is just one of many examples that
show how the functional logics of a
given technology echo the gender and
racial dynamics of the industry that
produced it here yeah this that's the
claim they're making the echo the gender
and racial dynamics and they actually
making a stronger claim namely a causal
claim they give you the other example of
the Amazon's recognition facial analysis
service previously demonstrated gender
and racial biases worse than those of
comparable tools so it failed to see
dark-skinned women while being most
proficient at detecting likes
light-skinned men and they later go into
this example again where they basically
also stayed yes this is an issue of the
dataset the dataset being much more
comprised of white men and they say but
then they you have to kind of make the
turnaround argument and say well the
dataset is a reflection of society and
society you know part of society is the
workforce and it's just not and eats it
again this argument only works if you
already believe the conclusion otherwise
it there's actually no argument there or
no solid one but what they do here is
they say Amazon's initial response to
such criticism has been to try and
discredit the research behind it
this reaction or let's let's first
discuss this
so the Amazon yeah Amazon of course
being the accused here and a
multi-billion dollar company and the
criticism is something that is PR wise
very bad for them a discredit the
research tried to discredit the research
behind it it's understandable that this
could be dishonest from Amazon side
right there I mean they're getting
attacked it's like the tobacco company
is trying to discredit the smoking
research but still I mean that doesn't
mean it's wrong it could actually be bad
research right do you have to actually
go and look at what's Amazon saying what
is the research really doing is Amazon
right or wrong completely open that
Amazon is is wrong here but you still
have to go look and this citation here
I've tried this citation here this one
isn't to a to Amazon's response it's to
like a a medium article and the medium
article doesn't even include Amazon's
response F of look maybe I haven't seen
it it doesn't also doesn't link
Allison's response maybe it links
something that links something or that
includes it in some way but basically
this medium article only states here
Amazon has been denying this or Amazon
has been critical of this and if you
state such a sentence Amazon's initial
response to such criticism has been to
try and discredit the research behind it
I at least expect the citation to lead
me to Amazon's response so that I can
verify what they're saying right so this
I mean I don't know I'm willing to chalk
it up to incompetence rather than malice
alright but then they go on and they say
this reaction is evidence of the wider
problem the research was conducted by
two well-regarded AI researchers who are
women of color by attempting to publicly
discredit their expertise and research
methods Amazon is reinforcing the same
kinds of prejudice and erasure that the
research critiques yeah here you go
straight to the idea
entity of the researchers you like play
the race card straight out I mean this
is this is maximum dishonesty right
except if Amazon said something like
well these women of color clearly
because they're women of color they have
no idea what they're doing or something
like this this is basically it's coded
language for saying either saying you're
not allowed to criticize people of color
because they're a minority or you're
basically saying Amazon is racist and
that's why they criticize them they they
just don't take them seriously because
they're women of color I mean both are
both are this is just dishonesty
really stated here - I mean again I'm
perfectly willing to accept that
Amazon's critique of this research is
wrong and is not well intended because
they're the ones attacked but you still
have to examine it rather than say well
they did shoot against women of color
and therefore somehow that makes their
their counter argument irrelevant or
even racist or something that's I don't
know I find this dishonest yeah I don't
know about you going on so they they go
on and state a number of examples of
kind of examples of bias and
discrimination in the workforce and they
a lot of times they make a mixture kind
of of the kind of gender and race
imbalance in a workforce and things like
sexual harassment not being taken
seriously by the companies and also the
things like gender or race pay gaps
which I'm open to to accept the these
things exist and or even intertwined but
just to tell you what's happening
because we're kind of skipping but it's
kind of a mixture of these things so
they say these issues are cysts
there is a close relationship between
these workplaces with discriminatory
practices and discriminatory tools a
feedback loop that is shaping the eye
industry and its tools so again here to
state I think I've stated it enough now
that were demonstrated enough that I'm
really representing their arguments as
they intended it to namely that there is
this kind of causal links and loop
between these two things again they
shoot against the fairness literature by
saying from this perspective sorry
from this perspective locating
individual biases within giving given
technical systems and attempting to fix
them by tweaking the system becomes an
exercise in futility
only by examining discrimination through
the lens of social logics who it
benefits who it harms and how can we see
the workings of these systems in the
context of existing power relationships
again they say these issues aren't
technically fixing these systems won't
help if that's the problem
and then I agree if that causal link
actually exists then technically fixing
the system might not solve the problem
not even sure I mean if you technically
fix a system like this then you
technically break the causal link and
thereby fix the problem I would oh sure
but again this is based on the
hypothesis that they've already reached
like demonstrated their their conclusion
which they haven't in which they are not
in the entire article yeah so the next
section goes into who makes I so I don't
know what about you but this section was
titled how workforces and AI systems
interact and apart from one the AI
system being used for hiring the
workforce which is I said it's one
instance where actually there could be
one causal direction from bias to
Minister representation to workforce
other than that there isn't really
anything in there
that really shows how these to interact
especially in a in a causal way all
right the next section is called who
makes AI as broadly about the about the
gender and race imbalances or miss not
unequal representation in the workforce
and we're going to skip this diversity
statistics that kind of that discuss
that diversity statistics of companies
aren't really accurate or can be you
know massaged kind of by the companies
which you know is true
definitely companies will always try to
maximize their profits and even if they
you know give out such a report so that
definitely critical thinking is in order
alright so the next section is called
the discrimination feedback loop right
if so if in the earlier section you felt
like here we go into the meat then you
must feel with this style like okay
we're actually going to see how this
loop works and how the two things are
really linked like how one causes the
other and vice versa so let's jump in
they say AI systems increasingly play a
role in our social and political
institutions including education health
care hiring criminal justice yes
therefore we need to consider the
relationship between the workplace
diversity crisis and the problems with
bias and discrimination in your systems
know why I don't see how therefore but
yeah so I don't see how therefore we
need to consider the relationship okay
if there is a relationship we need to
consider whether there's a relationship
okay
granted so they say fairness
accountability and transparency research
is playing an emerging role and what
they mean here is the aspect of fairness
accountability and transparency research
that shows that there is a problem so I
told you there's two sides one side is
showing there is a problem in current
systems and the other side is trying to
fix them so they're very much
fans of the side that shows that there
is a problem and they use show some of
these problems here we've already seen
some but they show some more like
Facebook's at delivery systems let users
to be shown as for housing and
employment in a discriminatory manner so
giving
20:19 study found significant racial
bias and a widely use commercial
algorithm used to determine whether
patients will be enrolled in care
management programs so the these are
these are just examples of these AI
systems being biased and they so they go
into this say taking a contextualized
view may enable a more extensive account
and the contextualized view they's when
they say this they mean anything more
than just a technical approach at
solving these problems more extensive
account of bias to emerge future work
could examine the politics of system
design study how they are systems in
situated reality and study air systems
and situated realities ask why a system
was designed in a particular way how it
was constructed who's interested shaped
shaped by the metrics in which its
success or failure is assessed rather
than solely focusing on improving
existing datasets or individual
algorithms yeah I agree I mean we always
have to we always have to pay attention
to these things especially like looking
at the metrics by which it's success or
failure is assessed but a lot of times
this is this is rather straight forward
in kind of if you look at the metric the
metric most often especially in
commercial applications is money right
so the metric of like an ad showing
system like if I have a system to
recommend ads to people show people ads
and personalize them and so on I simply
want to maximize my revenue so I want to
sell someone something and everything I
want to know is how likely is it that
person is going to buy that thing right
I that's basically yeah
so in essence sometimes it's really
valuable to consider what capitalism is
so in capitalism in so capitalism these
kind of this the system we're working on
is kind of a form of limited capitalism
but mostly mostly capitalism and
capitalism is very greedy
so capitalism all corporations want to
do basically is make money and there is
and on the other side you have
discrimination so discrimination meaning
these unequal represent an equal
distribution actively so an often
sometimes these go hand-in-hand
sometimes you can make more money by
discriminating against a certain type of
people and that's that's a really bad
scenario like that's a very like this is
really something where we need to take
action but a lot of times a lot of times
these two things stand in opposition to
each other so a little arrow here
non-compatible that means if I want to
sell someone something then I maximize
my profit by not caring by accurately
assessing how likely is it that person
buys that thing if I want to
discriminate here if I want to
discriminate start discriminating
according to skin color saying like no I
don't like that this person with this
skin color is able to buy this product I
want to kind of keep them down and so on
then I forego profit right then I
actually even though this person could
buy this thing
I forego that so often these things are
in direct opposition to each other also
if I am in charge of hiring and I don't
like people of a certain gender but they
would actually be really really good
whatever got good employees so I forego
that that means I'm getting I pay more
for less qualified people just because
I'm I'm biased and I'm down ranking
unjustifiably these people of the gender
I don't like so oftentimes you have to
ask yourself are people fundamentally
greedy or discriminatory which are they
more if push comes to shove would they
rather have more money or would they
rather keep their own race and gender
group in power and with just yeah so so
the and you have to ask this of
corporations you have to ask this of
people and in my experience and view
well-liked
people are much much more greedy than
they are willing to discriminate and
give up money for discrimination and so
if if we look at metrics by which its
success or failure of AI systems are
designed then I would I would argue a
lot of the times metrics actually profit
incentives and especially if we look at
data set construction if there is a
skewed data set that makes my a I system
be biased that actually loses me money
and the company would profit a lot from
building a better data set so looking at
kind of metrics actually makes a lot of
sense to me and very much in favor of
that and I think by by designing
accurate metrics and then getting the
best possible information the best
possible data sets to maximize these
metrics will oftentimes actually
eliminate such forms of discrimination
again there are situations where they
don't we have to
very conversant of these they go into
this and they say also examine more
thoroughly how societal discrimination
surfaces in data provenance examining
the history process of data set
construction and considering how
cultural norms and stereotypes were
enumerated and represented at the time
of data creation this is a big issue yes
so the the dataset construction kind of
at the time of data creation and so on
this was a big issue in these systems
and a lot of bias and I would argue most
of the bias we've seen here arises from
corrupt datasets and from data sets that
were constructed in an already biased
way and the AI system trained on these
data set simply replicates this this
bias so they I think I think that's very
correct here and they go into this
example they say the labeled faces in
the wild dataset contains over 15,000
images only 7% of images are of black
people and this is because these the
media landscape of the early 2000s these
images were gathered from the news media
at the time predominantly featured white
men in positions of celebrity in power
this exactly so if you train a system on
these then this data set the system will
inherit this bias yeah so this is a
classic example of a corrupt data set
also I mean this isn't only with with
race and gender this is also if you like
take pictures from IMDB yes a lot of
this currently sell up a dataset that is
used in all the gang research is
collected from IMDB you probably have
overly beautiful like pretty face people
on there like that so the Urrea eye
system your generative model is only
gonna produce mostly pretty face people
since movie stars tend to be a lot
prettier than the average humans so that
the kind of data set construction
process I think is currently the biggest
source of bias in AI but that also in
its
interesting that they go into this here
and they kind of want to make the point
that this is you know this is because
society and you know power in society
the data set reflects that but I would
argue if someone makes a dataset that
doesn't have this bias then the problem
is solved and I don't care who makes the
data set so the link between the work
force and the bias is really broken by
an argument like this because as soon as
we have a correct data set and unbiased
data set we can mitigate the bias and
they go they go into this here they say
sorry yeah they say down here they say
these people this um these researchers
have looked at these facial recognition
systems and they assess this what we saw
earlier higher error rates for darker
skinned women than for any other group
lowest error rates for light skinned men
to measure this disparity these
researchers developed a new dataset that
is more balanced both in terms of gender
and skin color good like problem like
make a larger dataset to actually train
on and then problem solved like and I
don't I don't care at all what race and
what gender these people are well done
like good people make if you good data
set like this and then we've solved the
problem what's the problem here like why
would you ever care what these people
look like if they if they do good work
that's to me that's this just this this
actually breaks their own argument I
don't know why they include it here but
[Music]
yeah to me that to then suggest that
there's a link to the workforces if it's
if here oh is obvious that if you fix
the data set you can fix the recognition
system
all right so we'll go on here jump a
couple more paragraphs except one they
say they shoot again against this kind
of say to this point a focus on fixing
technical systems in isolation without
examining their broader context of use
and power and dynamics that attends to
chuse is not limited in its intervention
it can actively cause harm so if you fix
the problem in a technical manner they
argue here it can actively cause harm
and the example they give is that facial
and image recognition systems they are
often applied in service of police
surveillance which disproportionately
harms poor people and communities of
color so there that this person there's
a quote from this person that says it is
not social progress to make black people
equally visible to software that will
inevitably be further weaponized against
us we are considered criminal and more
surveillance of not magnitude whatever
claim to a right of privacy that we may
have is diminished by a state that
believes we must always be watched and
seen so this is an example where by
improving the facial recognition for
black people
it makes them makes a police better at
surveilling them which is true and then
in it is an ethical problem that the
police is able to use these facial
recognition systems to surveil people
that's a massive privacy problem it's a
massive problem in how much the state is
allowed to overreach and so on so I
think it's a discussion itself but here
they they argue because at the very
beginning I asked you to remember the
this whole notion of we always have to
look at who benefits from the way the AI
system is constructed who is harmed from
that who is who benefits from how the
metrics are shaped and so on in this
case we actually have a perfect example
we
if the a if their facial recognition
system is very inaccurate for black
people's faces that actually helps them
in the societal context so by logic of
this report here that must mean that
somehow the bias like the the bias works
for them and thereby the system is good
or something like this and by fixing it
you actually make it worse here they say
it can actively cause harm
so I think this is a pretty much arguing
against themselves earlier where they
say or we always have to look at who
benefits from the system yeah here if
the face recognition system can't
recognize you actually benefit so I
don't think that argument works in any
case except in if you only look at it
when you want to look at it alright so
this we're gonna jump a couple of
sections here but the the the core thing
here was the feedback loop and again the
feedback loop isn't demonstrated at all
here just examples of systems that are
biased and of datasets that are biased
or because of datasets that are biased
but there's no demonstration of how the
workforce how I mean yeah just take this
previous argument so the workforce is
supposedly supremely white and it makes
a face recognition system that makes
that is performing poorly for darker
skinned people and that actually in this
context of police surveillance helps the
darker skinned people compared to the
lighter skinned people so that kind of
existing an exact counter example to the
argument that the but this room is
representation in the workforce leads to
the biases in the system if we interpret
it through the lens who
who eat costs and who it benefits all
right so the next section is corporate
diversity beyond the pipeline problem
and this is kind of an odd inclusion
when I read it first
to interpret to go against the pipeline
problem here but it kind of makes sense
if you if you know what these people set
out to do so what these people set out
to do is to argue we must fix the
workforce right we must fix the we must
hire more people of color more women and
so on promote them more so they have
have a very much have a problem with
this pipeline argument what the pipeline
argument is is the following so at the
beginning if you if you consider like
the educational career paths of people
again you have like hundred percent of
people that's represented at this at the
beginning and then most of these people
go through school so most of these go on
this is kind of the area in here is the
population and then some of them pursue
higher education like some dropouts so
this gets a smaller amount go on so this
is here this is time and this is kind of
volume of people and then very few going
to computer science right and then even
fewer going to AI so what you end up is
just a tiny sliver of people that
actually go into AR so this is called a
a pipeline and we have various junctions
here like where you would go into higher
education where you would choose your
major in university where you would go
into a subfield of computer science
where the the kind of volume of people
drop significantly from one point to the
other and now if you compare this if you
compare this and use it say we're not
considered all of society but here over
here we'll call consider all just men
and over here we'll consider all women
again they all go to high school and
then university and then maybe it's very
few go to CS even fewer go to AI what
you'll find this and I've drawn it maybe
wrong here is that this is smaller than
this so if you comparatively look at how
many male males end up in the AI field
you will find that fewer end up in more
and will end up in a field than women if
you comparatively look at it so at and
this is over time like at the beginning
you have 50/50 main women
distribution in society almost I guess I
think slightly more boys are born but I
could be wrong about this and then as
you go through time here this skills
that I believe so you go through high
school and let's just assume like high
school is still kinda equal depends on
the country then you go to university or
is actually more more women at
university slightly and then you go into
computer science and in computer science
and this is just relative here that's
why kind of norm it at a 100 percent
other ones these things would go down
all of them at the same time but
comparatively you have been much more
men than women in computer science all
right and then if you see who chooses a
I don't know if there's any statistics
of specifically choosing AI from
computer science I'm just gonna assume
that remains the same so if you look
into the AI field kind of this this will
stay the same so in the AI feel do you
have much more men than women and
presumably because you already have much
more men than women choosing computer
science as their major or choosing any
technical field as their major this this
is kind of the so-called pipeline
argument so where do a AI companies
hiring come in AI companies come in here
they hire at this point after your
university degree presumably there are
there's exceptions but just say they
hire after your University
and therefore they basically have to
choose from this distribution and if
they just say okay we'll just take the
the top I don't know ten percent people
will hire the good people of this we
don't care what gender they are right so
the top 10% here at the top 10% here
then this will end up being the same
distribution as you have graduates all
right so this is kind of the company
company hiring from and let's say an
80/20 distribution without looking at
gender we'll end up with an 80/20
distribution that's the pipeline
argument of companies and they don't
like the pipeline argument because the
pipeline argument basically says that
the problem is somewhere here right the
problem isn't the company's hiring
wrongly the problem isn't that the
company's here
deselect if the problem is somewhere
here and because they want to make the
argument that the company should hire in
a different way they can't have that so
they argue against it now to argue
against this would actually be very easy
if this argument were wrong like they
claim the argument is is is not good the
pipeline argument isn't good if the
pipeline argument were wrong what you'd
have to do is you would have to say you
would have to say hey companies look at
that in in your company you have an
80/20 distribution men to women right
that's pretty unequal and university
graduates the pool you choose from is
actually 50/50 so obviously you're
engaged in discriminatory hiring because
you know the pool is 50/50 there's no
reason why it why your hiring practices
should cause this inequality and
therefore we can clearly show you do
discriminatory hiring you should stop it
you should definitely hire more women
and people of color or more of these
more of them
Ortiz because your hiring practices are
the problem but that's not the case how
do I know because if it were the case
they would simply state this definitely
in this report if that were the case
that you could actually show with
numbers that the pipeline argument is
wrong then they would absolutely do this
instead they have to like go back and
they have to like ramble around it for
several pages which will mostly skip but
mainly because this is the case it is
the case that these companies hire from
a pool of of unequally represented
people and the only argument that you
can make is that well if if you were to
equalize this here then maybe here where
the problem is that would fix like so
the arguments often made if young girls
choosing their majors have no no one to
look up to like no strong women in in
corporation CEO roles they will think
that it's not a climate for women and
they will elect not to go into these
fields which is a valid argument like
I'm completely open to that to that
argument but it's the only argument you
can make and still then even if you
determine this as the cause I would
still not support racist and sexist
hiring practices like do something else
like make them clear that the
environment can be changed or change the
environment like change the if if it
really is the case that it's kind of a
non anti-woman environment change that
if it's just the case that they perceive
it as such change the perception but do
not engage in discriminatory hiring
practices because there's always someone
losing out unfairly on these practices
and that's that's a something I'm not
willing to to go into like that's
something I'm not willing to engage in
and I don't think people should engage
being
that actually that's why it's illegal so
let's let's actually look at very few
points this is just why the so they they
claim they go kind of go over these
pipeline studies and they yeah they say
the term used in the industry to
reference the absence of diverse
candidates in the hiring pool of to
justify the inability of large firms to
achieve diversity due to scarcity right
so that's they they basically agreed of
that on the definition that I stated
here so they companies that are
challenged on their lack of diversity
frequently cite pipeline studies as
proof of the persistent challenge of
finding enough women and people of color
to hire yes and and the yeah but they
say but the evidence suggests otherwise
for example in 2016 Facebook chief
diversity officer wrote that it has
become clear that at the most
fundamental level appropriate
representation technology or any other
industry will depend upon more people
having the opportunity to gain necessary
skills through the public education
system well yes that's something I would
agree and that's something clearly that
addresses this region here then and
where the actual problem is happening so
I would say that's a very very good
statement from the Facebook's chief
diversity officer they say but as the
Center for Investigative Reporting study
of tech company diversity data found
ninety-one large tech companies
headquartered in Silicon Valley managed
to hire higher percentages of black
Latino and multiracial employees than
Facebook that year well just if just
just because other companies employ
racist and sexist hiring to improve
their diversity numbers doesn't mean
that Facebook has to do this right this
it like just because other companies do
this doesn't mean that it's a it's a
it's a good thing to do or that's how
you should go about it
Facebook simply says like if we want to
hire without being racist or sexist if
we want to just hire the best people
then more of the best people have to be
in the pipeline like more people have to
gain access to educational opportunities
so we can then hire them whereas these
other companies probably make a big
effort to say well even if you are not
as educated if you even if you're not as
qualified as this other person will hire
you because of your skin color I don't
think that's that's an argument in that
in the favor of what the report is
claiming like I don't think that that is
evidence that the pipeline argument is
invalid all right so they're going to
core themes in pipeline research and
they do some they do some overview of
the kind of pipeline research that often
so sometimes the pipeline research
examines why why for example why women
don't choose to go into computer science
as much and sometimes they they focus on
what is their perception of the field
water it was what is their perceptions
of the stereotypes of the field what is
their perceptions of the kind of culture
the in the field is it suited to them
what is their perception of how
qualified they are for the field and is
that true is that false and so on so
this research examines a whole variety
of things and it's very interesting
actually to read through this research
on the point out this here other studies
suggest that gender is correlated with a
person's motivations for pursuing a
career in the field women and
particularly women from low
socioeconomic status or 'ti backgrounds
are more likely to see computing as a
versatile profession that provides an
opportunity for secure employment higher
pay and better social standing moreover
their interests go beyond technical
aspects of computing focusing instead on
the purpose and application of software
however such interests are often
de-emphasized
in computer science curricula a price
technical skill and its ability to
industrial in its applicability to
industrial settings above all else so I
find this really interesting
because it's basically saying that women
have different interests than men and on
average all right that's that's
basically saying that which is almost
heresy like to say this and in this
context like people will come after you
if you suggest something that isn't yet
they're just stating it here and
remember this for later this is this is
really funny that they're like they're
yeah the interests could be different
for women than for men and we might have
to adjust our curriculum to be more
suited to these different interests I
mean yeah I'm sure that's uh yeah as I
said you're like usually this is
forbidden to say alright so they go on I
say limitations of pipeline research
right
[Music]
these are fairly like common common
limitations let's say of studies in
general social science studies which I
won't go into much again they stay they
state we have to examine we don't know
we don't only have to examine this but
the problem they basically say the
problem is actually the culture and the
problem is actually the perpetrators
where they're saying I don't remember
where this is where this is stated but
they again say like we have to examine
who benefits from its present
construction like who is underserved
within the current tech ecology who
benefits from its present construction
how these dynamics might be untangled
and so on so um again stating that in
these kind of power relationships from
for the different groups which I don't
agree is in large part what's happening
they say it's worth considering the
scope of these studies and the by and
large the recommendations the issue are
limited targeted at the administrators
of university computer science programs
seeking to broaden diversity of their
student body yes that's exactly where we
saw the problem appears to be right so
that the reason they have a problem with
these studies is that they actually
focus on the point where this
discrepancy appears to happen because
they want to claim that no no no you
should focus on a different point namely
hiring in in these companies hiring and
promotion they say though important also
at least they they acknowledge that
that's an important problem this is a
narrow frame through which potential
solutions to barriers to inclusion it
does not address the companies that hire
computer science students the pier is
responsible for promulgating stereotype
views
or engaging in hostile behavior or the
broader social conditions that may
influence students success and later
science programs actually the the
research and even some of the examples
they've included of this research
addresses all of this like they they
research often addresses the kind of
stereotypes and the how the peers act
and how the companies act and also how
the companies hire and how the kind of
people have something to look forward to
or nothing to look forward to and how
that influences their decisions yeah
again they say the studies are
frequently cited by those within
corporate environments to justify their
own lack of diversity as they situate
the locus of change outside of the
corporation itself as such pipeline
studies are disproportionately
emphasized as a part of the broader
research agenda on diversity in
technology again they state companies
use this together and of course like
companies of course there can have use
this to get out I mean I agree at least
with that I agree that companies are
gonna try to use this to get out of
responsibility certainly all right
so the last section here is the pipeline
dreams after years of research again
this is on on this pipeline studies
basically say they say the pipeline
research hasn't shown like hasn't borne
fruit it hasn't led to meaningful change
in the field even though we've
researched this the reason they stay the
number of reasons they tends to place
the onus to solve issues of
discrimination Silicon Valley on those
who are discriminated against rather
than the perpetrators I find this word
choice really interesting perpetrators
right like again the group of white men
is trying to put down everyone else
that's the perspective that the article
takes and again and it's not even true
this research a lot of times it actually
says the reason why
for example women don't choose to go
into computer science is the the
male-dominated culture within these
corporations is the perception of you
know this of this not being a woman
friendly environment is the people here
of sexual harassment and so on so I it's
not even true but moreover I just wanted
to point out the choice of world here
perpetrators I don't I don't yeah I
don't know how you get to this word it
really shows kind of a world view of the
of the authors in my opinion alright so
they go on and say ok this pipeline
studies haven't been beneficial and
companies haven't done much or that it
hasn't been successful they're going to
work or LED initiatives which I'm going
to skip here it's just a kind of a
reporting of what happens at companies
where the workers themselves organized
and then the last section here is the
pushback against diversity so in this
section they're kind of documenting and
arguing against people who have
basically stated counter arguments to
their recommendations mainly so their
recommendations being let's change the
hiring let's change the promotion and so
on to to be based on race and gender and
the the pushback here yeah characterized
in different ways so we'll go through
this the last section I know it's a long
video already if you're still here like
the one person who's still here hi I
hope you're doing well
keep hydrated yeah so they say it's a
critical time we now see diversity
itself being weaponized
so they say this growing awareness
accompanied by demands for inclusion
equity has led to some change but there
has also been resistance especially
among those implicitly privileged by the
status quo so again jumping straight to
attack on the person like I don't care
if who makes an argument against me I
want to go on the argument and I'm gonna
go on the content of the argument but
these people straight first thing they
stayed is that's that's but but that's
just by the people who are you know
benefit it's just by the white men
basically straight to that identity of
the person that's dishonesty right there
yeah so those questioning and even
rejecting the idea that racism and
misogyny and harassment are problems
within the AI field and the tech
industry have appropriated the language
of diversity to argue that efforts to
improve inclusion are in fact
exclusionary and addressing the deeper
structural challenges posed by racism
sexism inequity is misguided and yes yes
definitely efforts improve inclusion can
be exclusionary like just because so
this is this is a thing just because
you're say fixing that's that's a just
because you're fixing a problem doesn't
mean the method you're using to fixing
it is justified and is itself good right
methods to improve inclusion can be
exclusionary and some that have been
proposed or exclusionary definitely it
depends on the method it doesn't mean
these people are against these efforts
it means that the measures for example
implementing racist hiring policy I can
definitely see that this is going to
lead to more equal representation within
the workforce but the tool itself is
really bad and exclusionary and
discriminating so
yeah I would I would say that's it's
it's it's accurate that they can be
exclusionary they say for example
somewhere researchers greeted the
announcement of black and AI workshop
Europe's leading machine learning
conference by questioning whether the
event was necessary arguing that it
would be discriminatory well can't they
can't they question whether the event
was necessary like that would I would
hear I would need a discussion what is
it for right
what why is this event happening and
what is it doing and is it is it
discriminatory like it could be like any
event can be discriminatory does it
discriminate based on race or gender or
anything is it you know does it do so
unjustly and old so I don't I don't just
don't see why question could still be
wrong
like you could question and then you can
be wrong but you should be taking on
your argument but the argument here is
just already questioning this is is
already on the wrong side of the
argument and I don't agree with this
though I don't agree with these people
that that question this workshop and
have a particular opinion on these
things but I have the opinion that you
have to take arguments at their argument
value and not just and who makes them or
whether or not they're against a
particular viewpoint all right so they
say such pushback often centers calls
for cognitive diversity or viewpoint
diversity the idea that individual
differences in the ways people think and
understand the world are distinctions
that should be counted alongside or
instead of other identity categories
such as race and gender well yes that's
it I mean isn't that is that very
reasonable thing to say isn't it very
reasonable to say that differences in
the ways people think and understand the
world there are distinctions that should
be counted alongside of
identity categories such as race and
gender they say a dozen white men so
long as they were not raised in the same
household and don't think identical
thoughts could be considered diverse
that's I don't know if this is a
sarcastic statement or not but really
it's it's kind of the the counterpoint
they're trying to make care that but yes
I would I would totally agree with this
statement in a way a white man growing
up in San Francisco a white man growing
up in a rural Idaho and white man
growing up in Florida a white man
growing up in Western Europe one in
Russia and one growing up on the road
with its circus his circus parents in in
Mongolia would definitely be that plenty
diverse right I mean they they criticize
this here but this is is actually how
can you how can you not see this that
yes these are valid differences and
people are going to think differently
independent of how they look people are
going to have different thoughts and
it's important to recognize other people
think differently and therefore you
should you know include them if it's
relevant and the counter-argument to
this is of course what the authors are
saying basically is that twelve at a
dozen people as long as they are don't
look the same could be considered
diverse even if they all were raised in
the same place and basically all live in
San Francisco and think the exact same
thing yeah that's I mean it sounds to me
it sounds as absurd as the other way
around it to me
so here's here's my here's a my thoughts
on this I am NOT going to pretend that I
know what life is like as a woman all
right I'm absolutely sure
that four areas of life it is it is
definitely valuable to listen to the
experience of a woman or multiple women
an aggregate of women because the life
is just different as a woman life is
also different as a black person
I absolutely concede that there are
things that I might not be able to draw
from my life experience because I am NOT
of that skin color that different
problems that people face and that's why
it's important to have an opinion of
that at the table but I'm also
absolutely certain that I have no
relation to someone who grew up as a
child popstar from the age of 12 and
then had that life I have no relation to
someone growing up under a communist
regime I have no relation to someone
growing up in in kind of a Buddhistic
religious tradition I just don't and I
don't care how they look they have
different experiences they have
different bodies of knowledge to draw on
and I don't think why we should make the
difference along the exact lines of race
and gender yeah well that's what they
that's of course what they argue here
those arguments work by centering
identity while flattening or ignoring
power relationships here the VP the
Facebook VP of engineering said that the
ultimate goal is cognitive diversity and
cognitive diversity is correlated with
identity diversity that means it's not
just about getting women in tech it's
about broad voices broad representation
right so the the this is exactly what I
would say the reason why we want
different but the reason why we want a
woman or a black person at the table is
because they have a different knowledge
is because they have different thought
because of their different life
experience they have different thoughts
that they can bring in so actually by
including these what they call bodies it
is about cognitive diversity even in
itself but the authors here really see
this from a different angle they really
see this in terms of power relationships
between race and general groups and I
yeah the arguments of the authors don't
make sense if you don't view it through
that lens and and that lens to me is
just such a it's such a I don't know
it's just sad look on the world and also
I think is a very very inaccurate look
on the world and it's I think a very
dangerous look on the world um yeah
again they say instead of looking at
historical patterns of marginalization
calls for cognitive diversity argue that
all differences are equal no we're not
like no calls for cognitive diversity or
don't argue that all differences are
equal well aware that some people have
it harder well aware that some
differences are bigger worse or better
that's absolutely well aware all they're
saying is that race and gender shouldn't
be the like only things to consider and
shouldn't be in itself be considered
diverse just because someone is of a
certain skin color
it doesn't mean anything right it
doesn't actually tell you anything about
that person so why not consider people
as individuals and look at what was
their life like until this point and
what could they contribute to the
discussion we're having rather than
looking at the color of their skin I
mean if the color of their skin played a
role in their life then obviously that
would manifest in my suggestion as well
but to just look at people through this
kind of group lens is is so foreign to
me and yeah I feel it's it's quite
dangerous
yeah so so again and this this could
argue that all differences are equal I
mean the point where you have to start
misrepresenting what the
counter-argument is saying that's really
how you know you're dealing with it with
not a well-intentioned person on the
other side of the of the discussion this
is really politics now this isn't a
well-intended argumentation it's really
someone - trying to achieve some goal
because they have to misrepresent the
other side and this only gets worse from
here
they say recently was exemplified in the
controversy over Google's appointment of
Heritage Foundation see ok calls James
to its advanced technology external
advisory council Google's reasoning for
the appointment of James was ostensibly
to ensure diversity of thought by
including a conservative viewpoint on
the council
all right so google has a technology
advisory board council sorry of external
people and they've included
a conservative and she is by all by all
metrics let's say a standard
conservative so this is not a far-right
neo-nazi type I don't know but this this
is someone who has similar opinions then
half the US country and in generally in
at least in the Western world generally
half of of the of the country's
population tends to be conservative more
or less I mean that there's differences
but yeah so this this is a this is an
opinion that a large portion of the
population shares so it would be I don't
know it would be suitable to include at
least someone of that opinion in an
external advisory council to to have
that on board it you don't have to
listen to her like it's not like she's
made King
it's simply that she will have the
opportunity to input her voice at
representative of kind of that large
very large percentage of people they go
on and say James is also a black woman
thus adding racial and gender diversity
to the panel so even further right this
is it's a conservative black woman all
right
but the pushback following James's
inclusion focused on her policy position
siding specifically her vocal auntie
LGBTQ and anti-immigrant views and
highlighted why cognitive diversity is a
particularly limited lens and the
pushback here was very much spearheaded
by one of the authors of this article so
I um this isn't just reporting
I will also I'll also criticized the the
this pushback here since its you know
it's kind of argued for in this article
it's not just reported and also because
the authors are the same so here they
say they have vocal anti LGBTQ and
anti-immigrant views and I haven't
actually gone specifically and looked at
what this person particularly has said
but given that she's a standard
conservative and has been in public
office I believe under george w bush she
can't like i have trouble believing that
she has like extremely hateful opinions
like these people shouldn't exist or
like something like that nature like
often people like conservative people
have have issues with forcing people to
adopt certain pronouns for people or
issues with which bathrooms do people go
in and you know generally are tougher on
immigration especially legal immigration
and so on i mean these are these are
views that people hold
[Music]
and a large part of people and these are
discussions to be had so including this
this person would be very sensible move
but they say in a letter opposing the
appointment a group of Google workers
calling themselves Googlers against
transphobia and hate
we had transfer peon hate responded to
the idea that diversity of thought
justified James's addition to the
council this is a weaponization of the
language of diversity by appointing
James to the IAEA see Google elevates
and endorses her view implying that hers
is a valid perspective worthy of
inclusions in its decision-making this
is unacceptable
here it says again the the author was
one of the organizers of that and that's
what they're saying here this the views
if you don't have our views it's these
are unacceptable views right it's a
valid perspective worthy of inclusion
it's what they're saying basically is
you don't even talk to these to this
person like talking to this person
considering their opinion you can still
evaluate the opinion but even
considering their opinion is already
wrong and that given that the person is
a black woman so basically they are
called the author's idea of diversity is
people that look different that are from
race and gender groups that have don't
have much power or perceived that what
they call power right now as long as
they all think exactly as we think right
then that's fine as long as they they
they share our thoughts as long as they
don't have dissenting opinions we want
the we want the different looking people
but don't dare talk to anyone of a
different opinion yeah this I don't I
don't see how I mean this these authors
in my opinion they really live in in a
bubble they really live in the in a tiny
Silicon Valley or Silicon Valley
influenced spaces because this is this
is half the people they're basically
saying half the people
in their greater community in their
country aren't even worthy listening to
their their opinions aren't even worthy
of inclusion in of consideration so yeah
well well done
might as well discredit them at once I'm
sure I'm sure
I'm sure that's gonna fly well with
these people all right yeah hmm let's
start calling them deplorable and see
what they do
maybe they'll return the favor and elect
a just to stick it in your face
and that's what happened so the idea of
cognitive diversity is mobilized by some
support in support that the AI field and
the tech industry are already diverse
goals for us to support claims that not
including identities like widened mail
constitutes discrimination yes it can
like if if you include every single
identity except white and male that
constitutes discrimination that's I mean
yes even if they're in the majority is
still constitutes discrimination like no
one can help being born white demille no
one white male chose to be born like
that don't mostly don't choose the
melanin content of your skin you can
modulate it a bit by going to the Sun
which computer science people
statistically don't do very often so
there's not much leeway there so yeah
this is to to not include identities
like that if you include every other one
can't constitute discrimination true a
July 2017 memo written by James d'amour
a software engineer at Google is
illustrative of such pushback titled
Google's ideological echoed
chamber and published in an internal
mail list memo critiqued the company's
diversity policies arguing the
biological differences between men and
women rather than bias and
discrimination help explain gender
disparities at the company
I feel the you can leave out the rather
than here
I think the memo simply stated that
biological differences can help explain
the gender disparities the most
objective writing the memo was to make
the case that policies designed to
achieve equal representation are unfair
divisive and bad for business
well some are yes especially the
recommendations that you've given at the
beginning number seven is unfair
divisive and I would also argue bad for
business yes
so supporters for the mores point of
view at times even drew on rather odd
part of the pipeline to make the case
that diversity initiatives are in fact
discriminatory they argue incorrectly
that if there aren't qualified
candidates in the pipeline then hiring
those who are unqualified of the basis
of identity discriminating discriminates
against those who are qualified no I
would I would say hiring anyone on the
basis of identity discriminates
I mean inherently so against I think
that's the I think that's the larger
argument that these people are making
which is not incorrect is very correct
yeah so in an update to the memo the
Moore himself asserted that he values
diversity and inclusion but his primary
concern was cognitive diversity
he says diversity inclusion is not
denying that sexism exists doesn't
endorse using stereotypes and in
specific I've read the memo and it
directly says these are these are
population level kind of statistics and
there is more overlap than difference
and you
absolutely can't say anything about an
individual by looking at these
statistics that's almost a quote from
this memo so he was very much concerned
with considering people as individuals
but also if you like he was basically
making the same argument as earlier I
told you to remember hey look the this
one stays described this one study that
found that women's interests might be
different and we might shape the
curriculum that's basically what Moore
said he said women's interests might be
different we'd have to maybe shape the
way we do work like change the way we do
software engineering to attract more of
them that's what was one of his points
so is exactly the same thing but of
course he's a misogynist because he
suggested that this could be due partly
because of biological differences and I
think it the way he was dragged through
the mud is just crazy
and this they shoot here very much
against this kind of biological what
they call biological determinism will
see this very briefly they say diversity
becomes an empty signifier stripped of
the histories and experiences of
systemic discrimination repurposed
around the ideology rather than bodies
yeah I'd say diversity has nothing
inherently to do with bodies like as
such I think that only that's only the
case if you are already convinced of
this that's a yeah within hours of the
memos publication harassment targeting
minority advocates who push back against
the claims in the memo began with a
particular focus on queer and trans
workers book that's bad but also I think
the pushback against people who voiced
support is also was also pretty bad
because one of them was fired as you
already stated
Google's vice president of diversity
even locked down her Twitter account
shortly after the Morris firing
responding to the barrage of threats
describing her as a police Nazi well
yeah if you fire something
I mean undoubtedly Google fired this guy
because they thought it was less of a PR
disaster if they also fired him now then
I mean this wasn't there probably wasn't
an ideological decision much much more a
PR decision but yeah if you fire someone
after stating like after stating
something like this it very much looks
like you're firing them because you
don't like their ideas and you don't
like what they're saying which generally
not in favor of censoring freedom of
speech but yeah that's being said
harassment is bad don't harass people
also that being said criticism isn't
always harassment and don't conflate the
two the mores memory memo also stated at
the distribution of preference abilities
of men and women differ in part due to
biological causes and that these
differences may explain why we don't see
equal representation of women in tech
and leadership this certain hinges on a
flawed assumption that identities like
gender and race are essential and fixed
biological attributes and that
inequalities are at least in part the
product of such irreducible differences
well I mean if they're not fixed
biological attributes certainly gender
and race have a 0.99 correlation with
biology or invent since your biology is
first and it's determined when you're
conceived that we that demonstrates a
causal direction right so even if
they're not exactly fixed they're like
overwhelmingly fixed and to suggest that
is a flawed assumption
that these inequalities are at least
part product of such differences what
you'd have to do if they simply state
it's a flawed assumption what you have
to do in order to show this is a flawed
assumption you have to show that gender
and race as far as they're biologically
determined have no influence whatsoever
on these differences that's what you
have to show right that's the
counterclaim because the claim is they
have at least in part something to do
with it and that's also I believe what
the molar stated and what did
predominant opinion it like it's very
like all the research points to for
example there is a large difference in
interest between genders as far as for
example career selection goes and so on
now we can we can talk about why that is
but there is also a large consensus I
believe that this s at least partly
determined to however degree but it is
at least partly determined by biology in
order to show that this is flawed you
need to show that it does not have it
can't have any influence right you have
to basically prove them the the
impossibility of this having an
influence which no one has done so far
much to the contrary so they simply
state this is a flawed assumption kind
of shows to me that they've already they
are there they're in the bubble and
they're expecting to speak to people in
the same bubble yeah so they they go on
and kind of discredit this as call their
biological determinism which yeah I
don't think that's a I don't think
that's a correct use of the term
biological determinism but you can judge
for yourself all I think these people
are saying that biology might have some
influence and we could adjust for that
it's not even right
it's not even yeah this comes up here so
conclusion conclusion finally I think
it's been two hours
sorry conclusion throughout this report
we've outlined the scope and scale of
the problem
tracing how the diversity crisis in the
industry and the problems of bias and
air systems are interrelated aspect of
the same issue no in the past these
topics are commonly examined in
isolation but increasing evidence shows
that they are closely intertwined No
there you've shown that they're parallel
you have absolutely not shown that
they're interrelated aspects of the same
issue and you have not shown that one
any one of these causal influences the
other that there is any feedback loop
you have not shown that fixing one leads
to fixing the other I mean you could
also like take a company that extremely
is focused on or like for some reason
has a different work force and then show
how their products with the same data
sets as the previous companies don't end
up being being biased probably not so
easy but again they're not none of that
is in the report there are many things
you could actually do to show what you
wanted to show but it's just not the
case in this article our analysis
surface two prominent responses to the
diversity crisis on one hand a worker
driven movement which we've skipped on
the other hand we observe a small but
vocal counter movement that actively
resists diversity in the industry I mean
what again what dishonesty actively
resists diversity I mean this the the
thought that these people stray around
like no I don't like I don't like to
other working people it's it's just so
absurd all they're saying is that either
we don't understand the problem in the
correct way or
our tools aren't appropriate to solve
the problem I think everyone has the
same goal of the workplace and the AI
systems being as fair and as
non-discriminatory as possible - I don't
the misrepresentation of the other side
is something that really bugs me and
it's something that these authors do a
lot so yeah I I lose my polite side
maybe and uses arguments from biological
determinism to assert that women are
inherently less suited to computer
science into AI what a load of crap
sorry but uses to assert that women are
inherently less suited to computer
science in it no one okay not no one but
no one that I know asserts that
absolutely no one that makes these
argument okay sorry
not no one you can always find a sexist
douchebag that makes that argument but
this this is not a serious argument made
and this is not there this this counter
movement most people in the argument
that most people in this country
movement make not at all and to
represent them as such is just so
dishonest that yeah this this this
basically this is the it's nice that
it's in the conclusion because it
finally like at the end it completely
destroys the credibility of me taking
seriously these authors I felt they had
so that the parts we skipped over
I mostly would say mostly okay with day
mostly show parallels between the how
that AI systems are biased and they also
show that there is unequal
representation they also show examples
of discrimination harassment and so on
problems in AI companies and
universities that all you can read the
report for this that's it's pretty
interesting to read but the points I've
addressed
I'm not happy with yeah so that was it
for now sorry this was took so long but
I felt a for otech was necessary have a
nice rest of the day